hey Vsauce Michael here and today I've
got a brand new episode of Vsauce
Leanback you can click this annotation
or the link at the top of the
description to start it and then you can
just lean back and let the autoplay
playlist bring the knowledge right to
your brain as you already know it
doesn't really work on mobile phones yet
so wait until you're in a better
position to lean back in the meantime
let's get psychotic no not psychotic
subhanak referring to what is known as a
saccade the quick movements that our
eyeballs make when we move from one
object to the other as you may remember
from a previous lean back some animals
like most birds cannot move their
eyeballs and so to look from one thing
to another they have to move their head
really really fast and to keep the world
from being blurry when their bodies move
they have to keep their heads completely
stationary but here's the neat thing
about saccade when our eyes move there's
a quick blur between one destination and
the other and that blur is completely
incomprehensible to our brain so what
our visual system does is erase it from
our memory and instead replace that
little fraction of a second that our eye
move during with the very next thing we
see this leads to a really amazing
illusion called the stopped clock
illusion you may have noticed this
before if you've ever been in a room
with a clock with a second hand like in
a classroom darting your eyes back and
forth waiting for class to be out now
here is what happens right when you dart
your eyes to the clock that very first
second that very first movement of the
second hand that happens when your eyes
reach it seems longer than every other
second afterwards look away from the
clock and then look and that first
second will seem to linger as if time
itself has stopped the reason for that
is that your brain replaces the time it
took for your eye to go from here to the
clock with an image of the first thing
you saw which was the second hand and so
that little fraction of a second of time
is added to the length of time it takes
the second hand to move what's really
mind-blowing about this entire effect is
that it happens all the time all day as
you look around the world from one point
to another
that little fraction of a second that
your eyeball was moving is lost and your
brain just replaces it with the very
next thing that you see now it might
just be a tiny tiny amount of time but
over the course of an entire day
those little fractions of a second add
up to almost 40 minutes 40 minutes of
every day that you're awake are lost
because our eyeballs move and as always
thanks for watching
so what are you waiting for click here
to start the Leanback or click the link
at the top of this video's description
you know what I totally never say that
yeah I'm totally heterosexual but you
are really attractive